support for expelled Tennessee
Democratic lawmakers is growing louder
State Republicans say the so-called
Tennessee three conducted a mutiny on
the house floor when they LED gun reform
chants from the speaker's Podium with a
bullhorn some democratic leaders are
calling the expulsion and embarrassing
stain on Democracy during a surprise
trip to Nashville Friday vice president
Harris met with the Tennessee three and
Scott McFarland reports from Washington
Scott good morning hey Jeff good morning
to you President Biden spoke from Camp
David with these two expelled
legislators and he called the expulsion
a quote blatant disregard for U.S values
the expulsions have drawn protests
condemnation and Friday drew a visit
from the vice president
protests grew in size and volume this
week outside the Tennessee State
Legislature vice president Kamala Harris
landed for a last-minute trip to
Nashville in a meeting with the two
Democratic legislators expelled by their
colleagues and the third representative
who was nearly ousted
[Applause]
until the people you don't turn off
their microphones when they are speaking
of life and Liberty
that is not what the Democracy does
Thursday's vote by the large Republican
majority to expel legislators Justin
Jones and Justin Pearson has triggered a
national Firestorm and as you see we'll
demand it in the house we'll get
expelled for it too and we'll demand it
outside the house
last week the pair and state
representative Gloria Johnson using a
megaphone protested at a legislative
session and urged for stricter gun laws
just days after the shooting rampaged at
the private Christian Covenant School
Johnson was spared expulsion by a single
vote and argued her being white might
have been the factor it might have to do
with the color of our skin State
Republicans argued last week's
disruption by the three caused disorder
and dishonor look at the disrespect
with which he has conducted himself
today
he called our speaker a liar
he pointed derisively at our speaker
he insulted each and every one of you in
Washington National Democratic leaders
issued blistering statements including
house Democratic leader Hakeem Jeffries
who said the expulsions were baseless
and that democracy is under attack CBS
News is awaiting response to requests
for comment Friday from Tennessee's two
Republican U.S senators
Monday afternoon County officials in
Nashville meet to discuss temporarily
filling the seat that was left by the
expulsion of Justin Jones they could put
him right back in his seat temporarily
until a special election in which Jones
can run again and local officials will
do the same in the coming days to talk
about the seat of Justin Pierce Michelle
all right Scott thank you